Då visste vi ju typ att säljer vi ut varenda blet, och det tror jag nästan att vi gjorde, så går vi typ en och en halv miljon back.
Det var väl lite dyrt, konstaterade vi sen jätterann, med tanke på att det är så mycket jobb jag har också.
Jag ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Löst det, vi börjar spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Alton Bladet sen.
Jag ska hitta på ett namn i henne på podden.
Är det den bästa idé vi har?
Det är inte den sämsta idé vi har.
Exakt, det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt, det kör vi på.
Det får det bli, klart.
Då går vi vidare.
Tjena tjena, då säger vi välkommen till Andreas från Tyngre.
Tackar, mysigt att vara här.
Väldigt spännande.
Detta är ju en av, jag har inte haft några önskegäster, men du är ju önskegästen bland gästerna.
Jaha, fan, så hedrande.
Du verkar vara väldigt förvirrad lysnarskaran.
De kanske inte har så stor syn på världen, utan de håller sig i den här bubblan helt enkelt.
Det är bra, det är ju härligt.
Sen tror jag att de flesta vet vem du är, men om man inte vet vem du är, så är ju du en av grundarna till Tyngre.
Just det, det är väl liksom min claim to fame.
Det är ganska kul när jag, numera har jag märkt att, alltpå mycket om vilka åldersgrupper man rör sig i, numera när jag träffar särskilt killar som är typ mellan 15-18 då, för att ta en riktig sweet spot, så har jag varit med i någon video med, du vet vem Samp är, är du så pass unga att du vet vem Samp vet vad det här är?
Nej det vet du inte.
Han är i alla fall en av Sveriges största YouTubers, och jag har varit med i någon av hans videos, och då har det liksom varit, verkligen inte mycket, det är inte så att jag och Samp har gjort massa videos ihop, utan någon gång har jag sett på någon video, och varje gång jag träffar någon 16-årig säger de liksom, ja, jag känner igen dig.
Och jag tänkte så, ja det måste väl vara tyngre ändå.
Att man stöter på, var inte du i en video med Samp?
Och då är liksom allt man har gjort i livet, är liksom kondenserat, det har varit.
All din prestation för jävligt.
Ja, det är det.
För de som är så unga då, så är det väl det jag presenterar mig som.
Men annars går du väl, jag gissar att du går under epitetet tyngre Andreas.
Det är så folk introducerar dig, där är Andreas tyngre.
Ja, precis.
Så är det väl.
I alla fall, åtminstone i träningsvärlden tänker jag.
Ja, det är väl det jag har pysslat med.
Nu är det väl nästan tio år då, så det börjar kännas som att det är så det är.
Men känner du dig känd?
Nej, nej det gör jag inte.
Tittar folk på dig på stan, liksom.
Nej, alltså i Stockholm så händer det ju inte.
Här vill ju folk vara så coola, till och med om du vore slatan ville folk inte säga något.
Men det kan ju hända om man är på andra ställen.
Det tror jag också är lite så här för att eftersom folk vet att man inte är därifrån så finns det ju en naturlig undran, vad gör man där så att säga.
Om man är i Sjövde eller nånstans.
Men det är väl främst om man är i träningssammanhang som nån.
Jag tror inte att det är så mycket när man är på ICA.
Nej.
Tyvärr.
Jag undrar om jag...
Jag hade nog tittat lite och sagt till tjejen att det är han Andreas på tyngre och så hade hon sagt, men fan är det typ.
Men fan är det.
Rimligt ändå.
Det tyder på en bra tjej.
Ja men jag tänkte också det när vi skapade relationlåt som ja, som att det var ett avtal men...
Men jag tyckte det var väldigt skönt att få en flickvän från icke-träningsvärlden som inte har någon koll alls på detta och som inte snackar träning hela dagarna.
Ja men det låter väl klokt.
Min fru jobbar ju med tyngre ska jag säga.
Ni slipper aldrig ifrån.
Nej, men det finns fördelar med det också.
Det gör det lättare.
Är du trött på träning?
Kan du känna att fan jag har gjort detta ett tag nu?
Alltså, det som är min fördel tror jag, det finns ganska stor skillnad mellan mig och Alex som jag har startat tyngre med.
Det är att han är mycket mer förankrad i fitnessvärlden.
Hans fru är världsmästarinna i fitness och han umgås mycket i fitnessvärlden.
Om jag ser på alla mina polare så är det ju ingen sån.
Det är knappt någon så styrketrädare att hålla på att säga.
Det finns väl någon men det är på en väldigt rudimentär nivå.
I min vardag så är det ju ingen nästan som pratar träning.
Det gör att det inte blir så jävla uttröttande.
Sen har väl vi lite också, om man kollar på vad jag och Alex har gjort, men det tyder väl lite på det du säger i och för sig.
Över åren så har vi liksom i poddar och sånt breddat det ganska mycket.
Då skulle man kunna tro att det är, nu vill man expandera marknaden.
Det är mer för att vi vill hålla intresset vid liv.
För om det vore, gjorde man bara fitness eller bara strongman, då tror jag att det i längden skulle, man skulle tappa lite av det.
Man vill ju gärna att, om man gör ett avsnitt om strongman, eller om man arrangerar en strongman-tävling, då vill man ju känna att det här är ändå inte någonting man gör precis varje dag.
Så det är väl det som är lite poängen då.
Däremot så tränar jag ju inte, för tillfället.
Jag liksom, jag boxas, men jag ägnar mig inte åt någon styrketräning, vilket är ju sjukt att förstå.
Det kan vi också bygga vidare på, men det är ganska många i våran värld som, vi har ju ett gymbolag då, men det är ganska många i våran värld som inte är vältränade.
Vi som är i bakgrunden så att säga.
Jag gissar att du har samma som jag där, att alla på företaget är mer vältränade än vad du är.
Ja men nästa, alltså man ser ju, det här kan man ju ha väldigt kul åt, på typ fitnessfestivalen, så kan man gå runt och se vilka som är liksom grundare av bolaget, för där är det liksom inga stora armar och så.
Men jag alltid tyckte att det här var ganska skönt, för jag upplevde liksom, alltså bakgrunden här är ju att, och jag vet inte om jag ska dra direkt men Alex var ju chef för att jag var på Bodymagazine, som var en väldigt stor tidning om styrketränning.
Den var liksom en av, sett per capita så var den nog en av världens absolut största skulle jag säga, när den var som störst, till och med större än de amerikanska.
Och jag började skriva för den då när jag pluggade, jag är ju ekonom egentligen, men så tänkte jag att det här är väl fästligt, för jag är styrketränning ändå lite.
Men ganska tidigt upplevde jag att det var jävla skönt och inte var, jag var väl vältränad med de absolut mest allmänna måtten.
Jag var ju starkare i bänken om du tog random snubbe på stan.
Du hade ett BMI som låg inom normalvärde.
Ja exakt, men det fanns då inte heller något att leva upp till.
För jag tyckte alltid synd om folk jag kände som de var kända för sin fysik eller vad det nu var.
Eller att de var stark och då var det alltid så pressat.
Var det någon som var känd för att vara stark så kunde det vara nästan problem att vara skadad.
För då var det ju inte så stark just nu.
Och vem var du då på något sätt?
Och var det folk som kom från fitness-svängen då?
Då var det ju naturligt så att de inte är i form varje dag, året om.
Särskilt, det här var ju också innan sociala medier, så fanns det ingen anledning att alltid vara i form.
Och då upplevde jag alltid att folk kunde vara lite besvikna när de såg dem.
Och det är ju trist när det kommer och folk säger ja, jag trodde att det skulle vara bättre än så här.
Så har det ju aldrig varit för mig.
För jag har ju aldrig haft någon claim att jag skulle vara så vältränad.
Så det har varit skönt också skulle jag säga.
Men har du fått skit för det någon gång?
Nej, alltså det har jag väl säkert.
Eller jo det har jag väl några gånger.
Det har aldrig bekommit mig jättemycket.
Det är inte något jag har lagt sådär superstor prestigier i.
Jag tror att det kanske är värre om man är...
Alltså det är nästan skönt när avståndet är stort.
Förstår jag menar det är liksom inte varit så att om jag går...
Det har varit nästan där.
Ja exakt.
Om jag har hängt med Josef Ehr.
Vi bara trashar sönder nu men du fattar.
Jag känner att jag får säga så för jag vägde mig här i förrgår och fick en chock.
Och så bara fan helvete vad det har gått ut förr.
Så jag känner just nu att jag får liksom vara med på det här tåget.
Jaja men alltså men det är rätt härligt.
Men jag tror man kommer undan mer.
Alltså om man inte säger någonting, det hade ju varit annorlunda om man helt enkelt satt och pratade om att det är så jävla stora armar nu.
Eller liksom vilken otrolig böj man har.
Alltså då hade ju folk liksom blivit lite så här men va fan snackar jag nog.
Men om man inte säger det, då tror jag det är rätt okej.
Men sen kan ju folk säga så här, ja, det kan ju hända i någon kommentar och så där, men det är inget jag ligger vaken över de nätterna så att säga.
Är du så laid back som du framstår?
Som jag framstår?
Ja men jag är nog det.
Jag är ju lite som en gås i allmänhet.
Jag är inte så känslig så.
Och jag är ganska icke-oroad och icke-grubblande som person.
Folk brukar ju säga att ja, du skulle bara veta hur mycket som pågår här egentligen.
Och jag är alltid så här, nej nej.
Här är det liksom, there's less.
Det är inget som pågår.
Jag är en simpel man.
Så att, ja nej men jag är nog ganska laid back.
Jag sa ju det till dig innan avsnittet här, det är ju mitt mål idag att få det att skryta lite och komma fram lite med.
Ja men det är bra.
Men jag tänker, apropå det här med laid back, har det varit en uttalad strategi för ni har ju era reklamfilmer som är som de är och ni har ju erat sätt att snacka och ni är ganska öppna och du är alltid ganska öppen i intervjuer och sånt där.
Har du någonsin varit nervös för att det ska slå fel?
För någonstans blir det ju okej när man är liten men ju mer man växer desto försiktigare brukar man ju bli.
Ja och man blir ju det på ett sätt ska jag säga.
Även om man är liksom öppen så får man ju, det man får vara lite mer, alltså det är ju inte som man kan ta starka ställningar eller israel-palestinakonflikterna.
Det hade ju blivit enkelt oavsett vad man säger.
Det är ju ett sådant råd till folk.
Om du säger att det är tråkigt att det dör barn, då kommer folk att skriva till dig och säga vilka jävla barn talar de om nu?
Är det de israeliska eller de palestinska?
Den typen av grejer får man ju vara lite mer mot.
Vi började göra podd 2010.
Dels så mycket färger som lyssnade.
Vi hade ju inte ens tyngre då, det var ju för body.
Då kunde man ju vara lite...
Man kunde väl ta en starkare ställning om man nu hade lust med det.
Men annars så tycker jag såhär, det som har varit skönt alltid tycker jag att om man bara...
Alltså, är man rätt transparent då behöver man ju inte heller oras för att bara ingen kommer på det här.
Att det är liksom, du vet, att det är socker i proteinpulvet istället för protein.
Alltså vad det nu skulle förstå jag menar, det hade ju varit jobbigt på något sätt.
Och därför tror jag att såhär, nej fan, det är liksom, det är bara vad det är om man gör sitt bästa på något sätt utifrån förutsättningarna och så.
Och tycker någon att såhär, det här var ju idiotiskt eller, ja då får det väl vara så.
Har ni haft det på något personalmöte?
Jag vet inte om ni har ett personalmöte men, du vet, har ni haft någon sån där, ja vi gör den här idén, jag mobbar min kollega här som vanligt.
Och så är det någon som bara känner, nej, det går lite för långt.
Har ni fått mothugg någon gång?
Någon som bara, killar ni måste lugna ner er nu.
Nej men, själva tyngdelsen är det alltid lugnt.
Men vi samarbetar ju till exempel mycket med Vitamin Well och Nocco och sådana där.
Och det har varit någon gång när vi liksom, när de bara, fan det här kan ju ändå tolkas fel.
Det låter ju som att vi bara, det är ju ett skämt.
Och de bara, kan vi inte ändra lite.
Sen framförallt har det ju varit gånger när man har gjort så.
Det som vi har mest problem med är ju alltid copyright.
Alltså förstår du, till exempel man, man kanske, för om vi spelar in en reklamfilm till exempel, det är ju ofta jag och Viktor då, då är det ju inte så mycket manus.
Och det innebär ju att man säger en massa saker.
Och då kanske man säger namn, förstår du, man kanske börjar skämta.
Okej, okej jag fattar.
Men då känner de sälj någonting och då blir ju juristerna då mindre glada.
Så det är mer av den typen av grejer.
Och sen så, men jag tror faktiskt aldrig att vi har fått en viktig förvånande eftersom det är så mycket i reklamfilmer, det är ganska mycket trashande av Viktor då.
Det borde ju vara någon.
Är det hans egna idé eller?
Var det mig i arbetsbeskrivningen?
Väldigt ofta är det ju hans idéer.
Men jag tycker att det hade tyckt att det var fullt rimligt, du vet om någon sån här, friends, någon sån organisation mot mobbning hör av så säger att, liksom, ja vi fattar att ni skojar, men det blir det ändå att ni skojar om mobbning.
Alltså, jag hade ändå köpt den synpunkten på något sätt.
Du hade inte ändrat någonting men du hade accepterat?
Ja, lite så.
Och om det är någonting, alltså jag försöker alltid såhär också, tänker vad gäller typ när folk känner sig kränkta eller blir ledsna och så här.
Så om det är någonting, om jag säger någonting, om det är på något sätt jag agerar som gör dig ledsen, och så kostar det inte mig någonting att ändra det.
Om du säger så här, men jag skulle inte vilja bli kallad för Joel, jag vill att du kallar mig för Gösta.
Ja, då kan jag väl kosta på mig att göra det.
Förstår jag vad jag menar?
Du spelar ingen roll.
Men du heter ju Joel.
Jag tänker för fan säga Joel.
Jag bara, vad fan vill du bli kallad Gösta?
Du spelar mig ingen roll.
Det är klart att jag gör det, om det får dig mig bättre.
Så jag försöker misslyckas än man gör, men om det är någonting man säger som man kan ändra utan att det behöver inte påverka hela mitt liv.
Det är inte så att du säger att du vill att du klipper gräsmattan varje dag, för annars mår jag dåligt om jag vet om att den är oklipp.
Det är ett bra exempel.
Nej men, skulle nån hålla av sig med någon synpunkt och det inte liksom, verkligen sätter mig själv i pinke, ja då försöker jag ju att anpassa det i så fall.
Ja men det är väl rimligt, det är väl rimligt.
Sen tänkte jag att vi snabbspolar lite, för du har ju dragit din historia med Tyngre ett ex antal gånger gissar jag.
Det får man gå in och lyssna på era poddar eller någon annans podd, men du var på Boddy eller ni var på Boddy, just det.
Du gjorde någon sorts förhoppningsförhoppning in i den världen och det gick ju skitbra.
Och sen gick ni över till Tyngre.
Men vad var förhoppningen med Tyngre från början?
Fanns det en riktig affärsidé där eller var det bara att vi har fått ihop lyssnare här, vi flyttar över och så ser vi vart vi hamnar?
Er åter senare skulle jag säga.
Alltså man skulle säga att mitt engagemang i Boddy var egentligen ganska begränsat, för det var bara för mig en frilandsgrej.
Alltså även om jag var ju där hela tiden, så jag tyckte att det var rätt fästligt.
Det var någonting jag gjorde när jag pluggade, och så här lite andra projekt.
Men sen med Tyngre, då var det väl ändå att man kände att man kunde göra det.
Det är ändå ganska många som lyssnar.
Och det finns ändå ett sätt som kanske kan finansiera den här verksamheten, för vi var lite sådär.
Eftersom vi hade varit inne i Boddy, så var känslan att reklammarknaden var sådär.
Det var svårt att finansiera.
Redan i Boddy märkte man att intäkterna där reklammässigt började vika i den tryckta tidningen.
Och de kom inte istället på online.
Det var inte så att det kompenserade.
Det var fortfarande så, även när Boddy Sight var mycket större än nästan den tidningen mot slutet så var det ju fortfarande så att folk var beredda att betala mycket mer för en annons i tidningen än för att vara på sajten.
För det var ju liksom någonting, du vet, tryggt.
Där såg det liksom loggan och så här.
Och dessutom började man uppleva att de där annonsörerna kunde ju också, man gjorde ett liksom smaktest av protein bars.
Då hörde ju annonsörer av så sa, nej det här var för dåligt betyg.
Alltså ni får inte ha med våra bars om de inte har högt betyg.
Och så kunde man inte jobba liksom.
Så vi kände väl, här fanns i alla fall en realistisk finansieringsmodell.
Om någon kunde tänka sig att liksom köpa kostningskotten eller kläderna eller någonting så kunde man ha innehållet gratis.
Men det fanns med redan från start, kostningskott och...
Jag vet att era t-shirt var överallt ett håll.
Ja ja precis, det var redan från start.
Vi hade dock inte klart riktigt, jag kommer att råka, man fick förboka proteinpulvet när vi startade.
För det var inte klart för en typ, vad det nu var, några veckor senare.
Man fick gå in och handla och så sa vi, vi skickar om några veckor, liksom sådär.
Men det var liksom den tänkta modellen, fast den var ju inte gjord som en, tanken var ju bara, man vill ju alltid att allt ska gå så bra som möjligt naturligtvis, om man önskar, men tanken var ju mer att, kan vi liksom dra runt två löner på det här på något sätt, så är det ju jävla bra.
Då är det roligare att göra såhär, än att göra på något annat sätt.
Och sen så naturligtvis vill man ju växare och så vidare, men det var liksom inte såhär, här är affärsplanen, här ska vi vara om fem år, här ska vi vara, alltså det var inte så.
Och när kunde ni leva på det?
Ja men vi levde ju på det ganska direkt egentligen, men vi hade ju nog så all milån och så där som hjälpte till.
Det var också så, jag var på en ganska bra plats i livet, jag hade liksom inga direkta kostnader heller, så att för mig var det lite enklare.
Det var ju lite värre för Alexander, han hade ju liksom fru och barn och sånt där, då måste man ju ha lön.
Ja, det är ju i princip att kunna säga, men fan vi tar ingen lön det första halvåret.
Eller vi har liksom, du vet, 10 000 i månaden i lönen, men det gick ju inte för honom då.
Ni drog riktiga löner direkt?
Ja, egentligen, de var ju inte astronomiska, men det var ändå lön.
Men det sköna var att jag tror att vi liksom sålde, jag minns att första dagen tror jag vi ändå sålde för 50 000 spänn eller någonting, och då kände vi väl liksom att det, ja men då finns det väl, kanske, om vi har tur då, någon bärkraft i det här egentligen.
Och sen har det väl bara från det rullat på egentligen.
Så var ungefär den korta storyn.
Har det varit liksom en rak linjärresa, eller har det gått i sådana, nu fick vi in de här som samarbetspartners, eller nu börjar vi hoppade, eller har det varit mer?
Det är inte bara linjärt kanske.
Man har ju stött på problem.
Vårt kanske största problem var väl när vi...
Vi har ju alltid tillverkat alla grejer.
Alla kosttillskott har vi tillverkat.
Vi har inte tillverkat alla kläder i Sverige då.
Jag minns när vi bytte fabrik en gång, så bytte vi till några som var jävligt seriösa, och de tillverkade läkemedel, eller fyllt läkemedel, men inte tillverkat i allt.
Men vi har hanterat det och så här.
Så vi tänkte att de här, och det var väldigt hög standard på allting, så jag tänkte att det här blir jättebra.
Men de hade lite för lite erfarenhet av kosttillskott, och så de gjorde en blunder där de hade, med sökningsmedlet så var det förvisso, allting var rätt, för de var väldigt seriösa, men de hade tagit en sort som var typ, nu kanske jag minns mer, men jag vill minnas att den var för grok.
Den löste sig dåligt i alla fall, sökningsmedlet, vilket gjorde att produkterna blev i princip helt osötade, och det ville vi ju inte sälja då, så då stod vi ju liksom praktiskt tagit utan produkter i, vem är du, ett halvår.
Och det var ju lite kämpigt då.
Men annars har det väl egentligen tickat på, det har ju egentligen vuxit som allra mest de senaste åren om man ser rent kommersiellt.
Alltså vi växte väl ganska snabbt sådär impactmässigt, alltså hur det var med poddarna och Instagram, alltså sådana grejer.
Men försäljningsmässigt så har vi väl blivit också lite mer, alltså vi hade ju aldrig, jag var ju alltid, alltså vi var ju alltid lite såhär, aj fan va tuntigt att hålla på med liksom Google-annonser och sådana där grejer.
Men sen insåg vi liksom då, efter ett gäng år, ja men alla köper ju våra sök.
Alltså så att om folk försökte googla sig fram och köpa tyngre protein, så kom de in på alla andra sajter liksom för att alla hade köpt.
Jag älskar att det är tuntigt.
Ja men det känns ju slet.
Hela världsekonomin bygger på Google.
Ja exakt, så då blev vi tvungna att börja med det.
Det är bra, det måste man ändå göra.
Det är ett nödvändigt ont liksom.
Så att vi har egentligen vuxit, alltså om man ser det rent kommersiellt, då har vi vuxit som mest nu.
Det fanns ju en, för alla som höll på med e-handel, så fanns det ju naturligtvis en pandemieffekta, som även för oss, men vi har vuxit ännu mer efter pandemin.
Även procentuellt av någon anledning.
Det är också roligt, för man skulle gärna vilja på att vi har gjort det här geniala, eller jag har jobbat så mycket hårdare eller någonting, men egentligen är det ganska ofta så att man har jobbat ungefär lika hårt som när man inte växer så mycket.
Men har du någon analys av varför ni fortsätter växa?
Det finns ju ganska många tunga utmanare.
Eller utmanare, ganska tunga etablerade kanske man ska säga också.
En grej som väl har hänt är väl att ett tag så var ju, alla de här bolagen drevs i princip med förlust.
De hade ju så otroligt låga priser.
Jag ska liksom inte namndroppa men du vet att de kunde sälja proteinpulver billigare än vi liksom köpte in råvasslet för, alltså på något sätt då.
Och då är det klart att det är ju en svår konkurrenssituation ändå.
Även om vi kan tycka att det här är jättegott och bra.
Som något annat är det så sjukligt billigt, då förstår ju att man kan välja det ändå.
Pris är ändå en tydlig faktor.
Men sen har ju nästan alla större konkurrenter i princip uppköpt av olika riskkapitalistbolag.
Vilket gör att de vill ha avkastning.
Så numera är ju inte prisläge, nu säljs det åtminstone inte med förlust, så gissar jag då produkterna.
För det är ju annars en liksom, alltså framförallt det som är vårt liksom åk, fast vi tycker väl det är skönt också, är väl att vi säljer inte så mycket sådana här spacer, alltså vi är inte så mycket så här fettförbrännare och test och booster.
Sådana grejer har ju allmänheten ett rätt bra marginal.
Alltså den typen av produkter.
Eller då häls-
och kostprodukt, alltså kan-jang-segmentet kan vi kalla det så.
Så det är liksom, medan Vasle-protein och sånt som folk tänker att det här är jättemarginal på sådant.
Det är ju ganska pissig marginal.
För att det man säljer egentligen är ju mestadels en råvara.
Alltså om jag kollar, det finns en skillnad mot till exempel det ni gör.
För det är ju så, det är självklart så att era priser blir ju naturligtvis i råvaruberoende.
Men det är ju ändå väldigt frädlade produkter.
Det är ju inte bara här nere ett ton stål.
Gör något kul med det.
Det måste ju liksom ha gjorts något med det där stålet.
Medan vasleprotein, visst det är klart det behandlas och det smaksätts och sådana grejer, men den stora kostnaden där är ju bara kostnaden för protein råvaran.
Det gör att det är ett ganska prispressat segment och dessutom så är det ju otroliga svängningar i inpriserna.
Alltså som nu då, mellan Q4-23 och Q1-24 så ökar då inpriset på vårt vasle med 40 procent.
Ja det är besökt.
Ja det är besökt och då kan ju inte vi bara, vi kan ju inte bara höja utpriserna med 40 procent, då skulle folk tro att man blir väldigt tokig.
Du vet, vi pratar ju om såhär, det är inflation på liksom 9 procent.
Då är det såhär, fan man, 9 procent, det är ingenting.
Alltså, den typen av svängningar kan det ju bli när man är i råvarubisnessen på något sätt.
Men du besvarar inte riktigt frågan varför ni...
Varför det fortsätter att gå bra.
Det var det som var frågan.
Jo, det ena är väl det...
Prisläget...
Det ena är att det är skitsvårt.
Ja, exakt.
Prisläget har blivit lite rimligare.
Om man kollar våra produkter mot de som ska vara budgeta, så är det inte så mycket som skiljer i pris.
Alltså, det är nästan samma.
Det andra tror jag väl är, det kanske är också lite att vi...
Man vill liksom inte...
Men vi...
Så här...
Lämna fram det nu bara, kom igen det är mitt mål där nu.
Men liksom, jag tar ju fram våra produkter.
Vilket är inte bara att jag själv bryr mig om hur de här produkterna smakar eller vad som är i dem.
Det är inte så att det är ett riskkapitalistbolag som säger ja, dra fram 20 proteinsorter och så smattrar man ut dem.
Och jag inbillar mig väl kanske, det innebär ju inte att alla våra produkter är goods gåva till mänskligheten, men jag hoppas ju att det gör att det kanske blir lite godare.
Att man kanske inte släpper igenom något där konsistensen är värdelös bara för att man har hittat ett kassin som är fem spänn billigare på ett annat ställe.
Den typen av grejer tror jag väl ändå kan vara en hemlighetupplust.
Det som rejän från början var att de andra har ju alltid varit så jävla corporate.
Det har ju gynnat oss jättemycket på liksom, oavsett om det har varit Instagram eller poddar.
Det andra har på något sätt varit så att nu tar vi ett affärsmässigt beslut att vi måste ha Instagram.
Eller nu tar vi ett affärsmässigt beslut att vi ska ha en podd.
Eller liksom göra reklamfilmer.
För mig blir det ganska tydligt att det sitter med styrelse och fattare.
Det här är nog bra för att sälja mer.
Medan vi kommer ju lite från andra hållet.
Kul att spela in filmer.
Och så ja, vad roligt att det sålde på något.
Jag tror ändå att det, plus att vi blir väldigt väldigt snabbt, det finns ju inga beslutsvägar alls.
Alltså det vill säga, om du och jag nu kommer på här att fan, vi har ju tagit fram en skitbra lyftarsko, ska vi inte göra den ihop?
Då kan vi liksom, ja absolut, vi kör.
Alltså så är det klart på något sätt.
Och det tror jag är en fördel att man är lite snabbrörlig på det viset.
Hur länge tror du att man kan, för det är en tanke jag brottas mycket med, för vi gör ju samma sak hos oss, det är egentligen bara ett samtal bort, så händer ju allting.
Men hur länge kan man köra på det sättet?
Ja det är ju en jävla bra fråga.
Det medföljer också nackdelar.
En grej för mig är väl att jag har ju väldigt länge pillat i alla delar på något sätt.
Det är ju ganska roligt när man har kontakt med riktigt.
Vi samarbetar ju väldigt mycket med Vitamins Well och Nocco och Barbels och alla de här.
Det är så färsligt när jag är i kontakt med dem då, med de olika samarbeten.
Det är ju ett riktigt företag så att säga, där det finns en ekonomiavdelning, där det finns folk som jobbar med marknad och folk som gör design.
Det finns ett helt team som sitter med produktutveckling och har koll på regelverk och blablabla.
Alla delar i det här bolaget tänker att jag jobbar med deras del.
Är jag ner hos produktutvecklare?
Då tänker jag att Andreas är också produktutvecklare på Tyngre.
Är jag hos deras ekonomiavdelare?
Då tänker jag att det är han som håller på med deras ekonomi.
Är jag med deras ledning?
Då tänker jag att Andreas är vd för Tyngre.
Är jag med deras marknadsavdelare?
Andreas håller på med marknadsfunkt för Tyngre.
Jag blir en mångsysslare kan man säga.
Det gör väl per definition att man inte gör alla grejerna lika bra som man skulle kunna göra dem.
Man hade ju kunnat bättre.
Jag vet inte, det är väl det som är nackt.
I något läge så, och vi har ju liksom hjälp, men man hade väl, alltså början man blir lite fler så blir det väl också att i något läge måste ju saker börja formaliseras, antar jag.
Man måste börja ha möten och sådana grejer.
Jag har ju aldrig haft liksom ett utvecklingssamtal med någon.
Där är jag såhär, ja men Joel, jag gillar det här men du får nog jobba på dina presentationer.
Alltså det har jag ju aldrig haft.
Det är väldigt sådär ad hoc då.
Så jag vet inte när punkten kommer.
Jag tror att en grej som har räddat mig från det där, vi har ju själva lagerverksamheten outsourcade ju vidräkt.
Vi kör ju såhär trevliga lag.
Okej, okej, ja det är ju en stor...
Ja, för annars så hade det ju varit många fler anställda och mycket mer att hantera, alltså därmed rent praktiskt.
Nu är Roffe sjuk, hur ska vi sköta den här inleveransen och sådär.
Den har ju inte haft på samma sätt då.
Ja det är smidigt, men hur många är ni idag?
Ja, hur många är vi då?
Alltså vi är väl...
Det beror på lite hur man räknar, vi är väl liksom fem...
Vi säger heltidsanställda, liksom.
Ja fem stycken är vi.
Och ni omsätter?
Vi omsätter väl, jag har inte sett, kan vi omsätta 160?
Ja, det är en helt surrealistisk omsättning per person.
Ja, det låter ju otroligt.
Ja men jag har svårt att, jag försöker komma på om jag vet något företag som har bättre inom i handelsvärlden här, men jag har svårt att tro det.
Alltså omsättning per person.
Vi har ju lite fusk i det här.
Och det är ju till exempel i det här samarbetet med Vitamin Well, som jag pratar nu så mycket om, så är det ju så att vi hjälper dem med till exempel marknadsföring, event, lite pilla med produktutvecklingen.
Jag har varit med och liksom tagit fram proteinbar, alltså allt möjligt sådant.
Och de i sin tur, det gör ju även att jag använder mig av deras resurser ganska mycket.
Så till exempel då, som den här missen med den där fabriken jag talade om, att jag inte, jag har ju liksom ingen, jag har ju inte pluggat liksom livsmedelscertifikat i 20 år, så att om vi har en leverantör, då sköter ju de all den kontrollen.
Eller liksom märkning av produkter.
Jag fattar ju, jag vill ju skriva som det är, men det räcker ju inte.
Det måste ju liksom, om du ska göra en baksida som är korrekt, då måste det liksom, så här måste uppställningen se ut, och ingredienserna måste vara så här.
Det är inte så här, om jag skulle tycka att nej nej, det blir tydligare för konsumenten om jag spesar upp så här.
Det hjälper ju inte, det är inte så det ska vara.
Så detta innebär ju att, hade jag inte haft det samarbetet, då hade jag säkert behövt ha ytterligare några.
Förstår jag menar, som kunde liksom, men nu blir det, så jag har ju liksom den organisationen på något sätt att luta mig mot.
Även om ni dubblade er organisation hade du fortfarande varit ganska surrealistisk.
Ja men sen har vi vuxit mycket omsättningsmässigt de senaste åren.
Det är väl det också, det var väl mer rimligt förut.
Men visst, vi är inte så många i relation till omsättning.
Men Eanderl är ju, om man har lagret outsourcet, så är det ju inte så att, alltså växer man 10 procent, då ökar ju inte mängden jobb med 10 procent.
Men det ökar, oavsett.
För det är ju fler ordrar som något ombud slarvar bort.
Det är många saker, fler grejer som är problem helt enkelt.
Till exempel nu har vi blivit tvungna att göra om.
Vi byter motor på hela sajten då.
Och det är ju ett ganska stort...
Vi hade ett jätteproblem.
Vi släppte en Nocco-julkalender.
Jag vet inte om du råkade se det.
Den var liksom så hosad då att...
Vad fan var det?
Det var liksom...
När den skulle släppas så satt 15 000 perser inne på sajten samtidigt och klickade refresh för att knipa en kalender.
Så sajten kraschade då i åtta timmar.
Med mycket problem.
Nu håller vi på att uppgradera sajten till en helt annan motor och sådär.
Så det är ju sådana här grejer och då behöver man externa hjälp.
Det är inget vi kan rådda ihop själva då.
Vad kör ni på en system idag?
Det är ju en nördig fråga, det är bara jag som tycker det.
Idag kör vi ju, jag tror att vi kör ju WooCommerce alltså.
Jag tror att vi är en av Sveriges största WooCommerce-sajter.
Ja det måste det nog vara, det känns lite oldschool.
Ja men lite så, men det har liksom funkat bra då.
Det har inte varit något problem.
Med den typen av trafik så är det inte riktigt skalbart liksom.
Det finns vissa andra nackdelar också då.
Nu ska vi byta till Sentra, om du har hört tal som det.
Okej, ja.
Det är väl lite trendigt, eller inte trendigt, men det är väl många bra företag som har bytt det.
De säger det till mig.
Jag hoppas att det stämmer.
Det är dyrt i alla fall.
Då måste det vara bra.
Ja jag tänker det.
Jag tänker, jag tar den här direkt.
Ni har ju pratat en del om, eller du pratade lite om Vitamin Well här.
Och jag knarkar ju bokslut och alla bolag.
Jag läser ju på om alla i branschen, det är det roligaste jag vet.
Det är festligt.
Ja.
Då såg jag att ni ändrade lite i, ja, era styrelser där tror jag.
Ja precis.
Alltså egentligen gör vi renodlar upp det här nu så att, utan att liksom sitta på förhög, som journalist testar, så gör vi så att.
Tronligt ska det vara och intrikat.
Ja verkligen.
Vi är ju inte granskande och sådär, det är ju inte det.
Mestadels är vi ju liksom, det här kan ju vara viktigt att ta med oss från början också, att jag liksom ju aldrig, Längsbeintroade.
Vi har ju alltid sett det som att vi är rent traditionellt då i underhållning eller inspirationsbranschen.
Egentligen.
Det är ju det vi gör.
Det är ju inte så att vi ju så här, nu granskar vi liksom, vi testar om Eleikos nya skivs, de verkligen håller det de säger eller vi provar dem, alltså sånt håller vi inte på med.
Vi liksom, om vi gör en podd och intervjuar folk, då har vi ju inte dem där för att försöka klämma dit dem.
Sa inte du att du åt kyckling förra deten?
För ja vi har sett att du åt torsk.
Alltså det gör vi inte.
Men, med det sagt så tycker vi liksom, det är lite förkladdigt om, alltså vi separerar ut den redaktionella verksamheten så att hela vitamin well-samarbetet ligger på produktsidan.
Alltså så att det här jag talar om är liksom, hela samarbete med dem är kring produkterna och sen allt som är redaktionellt, alltså artiklar, podcasts, videos och så vidare, det lägger vi liksom i ett eget bolag så att man kan känna att det bolaget är litet och vackert.
Ja, förstås.
Det blir fristående att få göra lite som du vill.
Men kommer ni samarbeta kring produkter?
Är det framförallt tillverkningskedjan och logistiken?
Ja, exakt.
Distributionen också.
Vi har ju haft det samarbetet jätteligt.
Under väldigt lång tid har Vitamins Well hjälpt oss med hela distributionen i dag, då var det handeln.
Som jag sa, allt med fabriker och inköp.
Det kan ju vara till exempel sådana grejer.
Eftersom de då tränar ner ett riktigt företag så är det liksom så att om det ska köpas in, om det är något problem, så kan man ju höra av mig till dem och säga att ni köper ju in...
Jag hittar inte det här kakaot jag alltid använder.
Ni köper ju ändå in lite till era jävla proteibars.
Och så säger de självklart, här har vi liksom.
Och det är jävla skönt.
Det här har ju gett mig, man tänker inte ens på hur många problem det har undvikit, men det har ju gjort under ganska lång tid.
För vi börjar samarbeta med dem.
Alltså egentligen är det så här att ingången dit, att hon som är marknadschef för hela Vitamin Well, har jag gått på gymnasiet tillsammans med.
Jaha, över random.
Ja precis, och då skulle de starta Nocco, och då sa de, kan inte du hjälpa oss här, för du är ju inne i träningsvärlden.
Och så var vi igång med det, och så startade de Barbell, så där var vi ju väldigt involverade med Barsen och så där.
Och det här innebär ju att vi alltid har haft väldigt mycket samarbete, och ännu mer de senaste åren.
Så att även om man har varit ett väldigt litet företag, som alltid kunnat känna en trygghet i det, att kommer någon som skickar ett jätteavtal, då går jag ju med avtalet till Vitamin Wells legal avdelning.
Och säger kan inte ni kolla på det här, så jag inte behöver.
Och så vidare och så vidare.
Så att det har varit lyxigt så att säga.
Men vad är tanken med det här lite mer etablerade samarbetet, och är det att ni ska ut ännu mer, ska ni ut i världen?
För ni måste väl vara väldigt etablerade i Sverige, men hur är det utomlands?
Ja, vi ju, alltså ja Vitamin Well är ju väldigt etablerade utomlands.
Jag tror ju att Tyngre har liksom, jag säger inte att Tyngre inte kan köra internationellt, men vi är ju väldigt svenska i vår approach.
Har ni kollat om heavier.com?
Ja exakt.
Det har väl också varit en liten styrka, det andra har varit lite mer generiskt.
Allt vårt har ju varit baserat på Sverige.
Alltså smakerna har varit baserade på Sverige, allt har varit på svensk.
Så jag tror att vi möjligtvis i något läge kommer vi säkert att försöka, för vi får alltid förfrågningar från Norge och Finland.
Så att Norden är väl realistisk, men skulle man ha att säga att du nu sa så här, ja men fan, Tyskland är en så jävla maffymarknad, vi borde inte köra tyngre där.
Och det skulle vi kunna göra men då är det ju bara liksom som random produkt.
Alltså jag menar det kan ju funka ändå, men det finns ju inget annat bakom.
Det finns ju inte liksom att det, du vet, det här redaktionellt och det faller ju.
Det bryr sig ju inte tyskarna om.
Så det är ingen sån här...
Men ni har inte startat några små satsningar utomlands som ligger och puttar allt på?
Vi har ju, man kan beställa från Finland.
Men vi har ju alltså inte ens sida ny på svenska.
Alltså det är liksom, man riktar sig mot en ganska liten del av Finland då egentligen.
Plus att man kan ju inte leverera, en av de stora delarna som skulle kunna tänkas köpa är ju Åland.
Dit går det ju inte att skicka, det kostar ju typ 300 spänn i tull per paket eller någonting då.
Så att det är väl graden av internationalisering.
Men jag tror ju så här att, jag inbillar mig att vi fortfarande har lite mer växande att göra även nationellt så att säga.
Dels för att, ja det finns väl två varianter då, det ena är väl om man tar så att säga marknadsandelar, men sen är det ju också, jag är inte så jävla konkurrentorienterad om jag ska vara ärlig.
För jag tycker att folk är lite för mycket in i det här att, som att det vore en kaka man skulle dela upp.
Jag ser ju liksom, alla som gör något i träningsbranschen, känner jag på något sätt gynna mig.
Om ni gör någonting, även om ni är liksom i ett segment som då är lite utanför vårt, ja det är ju bara positivt, alltså förstår du, drar ni någon uppmärksamhet i tränningspersen och någon jävla tränare som annars inte skulle ha tränat, ja det är väl skitbra, alltså liksom så.
Så jag tror att man är lite för rädd, det var väl framförallt en situation kände jag tidigare i kost-
och skottsbranschen där det fanns liksom, i princip två stora aktörer som liksom bara upplevde att kolla på varandra.
Alltså aha, Joel tar du liksom 149 spänn nu, då tar jag 148.
Och liksom sådär.
Det tror jag inte man behöver göra.
Jag tror inte man mår bra heller av att bara sitta och bry sig om vad alla andra gör egentligen.
Så att, ja.
Nej och jag tror att det är ganska, det är lite halv, vad ska man säga, det är lite halv 30 att säga så, för att det är bara de som vinner som kan säga det meningen.
Men du har ju också en poäng för att ofta börjar man ju köpa, alltså man köper way åt i ofta det folk köper när de börjar och sen testar man sig vidare liksom.
Så att det är ofta en instegsväg kanske till att börja med protein.
Vi såg ju under corona att folk började köpa jättemycket usla hemmagym som var katastrofal kvalitet.
Men då köpte de ju dem och sen efter corona märkte de att om vi tränade mer hemma då köpte de våra grejer istället.
Så att de hade ju inte köpt gym från början om inte de hade köpt ett billigt gym från början.
Nej men precis så, de valde ju inte troligtvis heller mellan att köpa er grej direkt eller det här.
Utan alltså om man första gången tänkte sig att jag ska köpa hem ett par hantlar, ja men då går man väl till stället.
Tänker man att det här vill jag inte lägga så jävla mycket på ändå.
Det är dyrt nog ändå.
Alltså liksom så.
Och sen tycker man att det är bra.
Det är samma med protein, så om man börjar med yoghurt typ.
Och sen bara, nej choklad.
Och sen vill man ha något roligare efter året.
Vill man ha en kladdkaka sen.
Ja, nej men lite så.
Men sen har vi alltid varit så här, vi har ju, vi ändå ganska tidigt sa ja Alex att vi vill liksom göra de grejer vi tycker är kul.
Vilket innebär att vi ju haft ganska många projekt som har varit som egentligen rent kommersiellt inte har, de har inte, till exempel vi släppte ut vin.
Och där var vi väldigt tydliga med då när vi tog fram det.
Ligger helt rätt i.
Ja exakt.
Ja men då var vi jätte, vi får inte tjäna en spänn på det här.
För det var så kul då för det är väldigt hårt reglerat hur man får tala om det.
Och för oss gick ju hela, vi tyckte ju att det var kul.
Vi ville prata om vårt vin.
Alltså för vi tyckte att det var gott och så här.
Och det får du ju inte säga, om det här är en kommersiell krok att du liksom tjänar 10 spänn per flaska, då får du inte säga någonting.
Och då fanns ju ingen poäng med att ta fram ett vin.
Så att vi, det var ju väldigt speciellt då att vi tog fram det ihop med en vinproducent.
Då sa vi att det är väldigt viktigt i avtalet här att det står att vi ska tjäna noll kronor.
De bara, aha, liksom.
Så det här är vi gjort.
Sen är det ju ofta så att man har ju bara en begränsad tid så man kan inte lägga hur mycket tid som helst på de här passion-projekten.
Våra events till exempel är ju lite en hybrid kan man säga.
För man får ju marknadsföring då, är ju positivt av dem.
Men vi är ju aldrig tjänar pengar på dem.
Vi räknar ju alltid, om vi tar på oss att göra något, då sätter vi oss alltid och kalkylerar såhär.
Kommer vi kunna gå med en rimligt liten förlust på det här?
Det var ju som mest extremt när vi gjorde, på något tillfälle, hyrde vi Kista-mässan.
Då visste vi att säljer vi ut varenda biljett, och det tror jag nästan att vi gjorde, så går vi 1,5 miljon back.
Det var väl lite dyrt konstaterade vi sen efter, med tanke på att det är så mycket jobb vi har också.
Det var tur att ni inte hade riskkapitalister.
Ja exakt, men på samma sätt har vi gjort utrustning också.
Det var också en sån här grej att vi kände att det här tjänade vi, det var ändå pluspengar i det, men det var ju inte någonting, vi hade aldrig någon plan på att vi skulle in på utrustningsmarknaden, utan vi tänkte att det här är kul.
Men det gick väl ändå ganska bra, jag tycker att jag såg era grejer ganska snabbt etablerat, så varför fortsatte ni inte med det?
Ja men det var liksom lite för mycket jobb, jag ska inte säga att vi aldrig någonsin kommer göra, logistiken är ju inte underbar.
Nej, vi är ju inte uppsatta för det där heller, det är ju för tunga grejer, vi skickar ju påsar.
Men man kan säga så här att det var mycket jobb för att hålla igång, vi gjorde ihop med några andra.
Det var väl liksom, vi kände väl att det var lite så där.
Sen var väl typ, det roligaste är väl egentligen viktskivorna, för då står det ju tyngre överallt.
För jag menar, det är det.
Vi liksom, stängen är ju kul, men de är ju, dels är det ju mycket mer jobb för att göra en stång.
Alltså en bra viktskiva, det går ändå att göra liksom lite mer, alltså det finns en mold, och så gör man det liksom.
Men en stång, det är ju ganska mycket meck, och sen så var det ju så här, vi upptäckte väl också att, man skulle göra världens bästa skivstång, vi leker med att du tar fram världens bästa skivstång, om det nu fanns en sån definition.
Så är det ju ändå inte tillåten att köra i några tävlingar, oavsett om det är tyngdlyftning eller styrkelift.
Och då tänkte vi att man kanske skulle sätta dem här, så att man får tävla med dem.
Du ringer på en jobbig rutt.
Ja, för att det här var styrkelyftat.
Då förutsatte vi att den stora biten skulle vara att de ville liksom...
Vi insåg ju att de ville ha spesen.
Exakt, att de skulle testa den och se...
Jag tycker bara att det här är kul att jag jobbar i denna världen.
Det framstår ju som naivt nu men jag tänkte naturligtvis att det här kommer att kosta några pengar.
Absolut.
Men de kommer att vilja hårtesta och säga att den här stången är verkligen...
Eller den är inte tillräckligt bra av någon anledning.
De bryddes ju noll om utrustningen.
De som bara, så här mycket kostar det.
Och vi bara, vad vill ni ha grejer?
Nej, vi behöver inte ens kolla på grejer.
Alltså det var liksom...
Vi hade kunnat gjort en stång som var gjort i typ plast, om vi bara hade betalat.
Så hade den helt plötsligt varit godkända.
Och då blev vi lite desillusionerade kring det här med att...
Är det inte alltid lässamt när man känner hur den här barnnaiviteten dör inom...
Ja, verkligen.
Särskilt så här, det finns ju någonting att man alltid tänker, när det är saker som framstår.
Jag har ju alltid lite problem med ideella verksamheter av just denna anledningen.
För att det ofta är...
Det låter så fint.
Det är inte ideellt.
Det är därför jag gillar det kommersiellt.
För då säger folk, vad gör du såhär?
Nej men jag vill få intäkter.
Ja men det är bra.
Då är vi tydliga med det liksom.
Sen så finns det ju verkligen så här...
Jag nämnde ju Josef Eriksson här tider till exempel, att jag inte var lika stark som han är bänkpröster.
Men det är ju en typ som person som...
Han jobbar ju verkligen jätte...
Han gör ju jättemycket ideellt.
Liksom, och som han då inte...
Du vet, han vill helst aldrig ha betalt för någonting och så där.
Så det finns ju de grejerna, men så fort man börjar ta sig upp i olika förbund, och det är inte just inom styrketräning, det är inom allt, då är liksom den ideella verksamheten otroligt skenbart ideell.
Och nästan mer kommersiell än den kommersiella.
Alltså, otroligt nog.
Ja, så är det verkligen.
Eller det blir hyckleri, kan jag säga.
Framförallt är det hyckleri.
Det är fruktansvärt.
Om det ska vara på ett sätt så bara säger jag så.
Jag menar det.
Så spelar vi med öppna kort i alla fall.
Det är liksom, ja.
Nej, så att, nu vet jag inte heller vad jag svarade på men.
Nej, jag har ingen aning eller.
Men det är om det.
Ja, men, och apropå den här internationella satsningen, säger jag om vi pratar om att växa då.
Så, du sa ni gör ju inte sådana här testo-boosters och alldeles.
Anabolic Fluids, typ, men varför gör ni inte ett instick i den världen?
Eller inom hälsokost?
Finns det en tanke där eller är det bara som med Google att ni tycker det är lite löjligt och sen går ni in där?
Ja, exakt.
Alltså man kan säga så här.
Självklart så är det ju så att om kunderna efterfrågar någonting väldigt mycket, då försöker vi ju släppa det på något sätt.
Men det finns ändå lite gränser där kan vi tycka, och nu låter man så jävla ädel igen, men ta en sån produkt som test och boosters, det finns ju bara två alternativ.
Om du säljer en test och boosters, antingen funkar den och då säljer du dopning, eller funkar den inte och då säljer du bluff, och det generellt funkar den ju inte då.
Vitaminer och sådana grejer, där är det vi är helt okej med att sälja, så länge man inte klamar någonting annat.
Om det är för att du vill ha mer D-vitamin.
Men om vi börjar säga att ta den här D-vitaminen för att, för det kommer vi säkert på att det ger bättre träningstestat, eller du kommer vara frisk som jävlarna, då har vi gått över gränsen.
Vi klamar ju alltid extremt lite kring våra produkter också.
Det var också någonting, vi orkar liksom inte med det här.
Alltså koste i skottsbranschen var ju väldigt speciale för den var ju så baserad på att, du sponsrar någon boddbilder och så sade du liksom att, tar du det här vasleproteinet, då blir det Ronny Coleman.
Alltså det här vasleproteinet, då blir det bara det här, alltså så.
Och det där kunde, vi fick ju direkt frågorna liksom, ja men, om jag har tränat, måste jag liksom dricka ett vasleprotein?
Kan jag inte äta mat då?
Och då sa vi så, jo du kan ju äta mat naturligtvis.
Och då har folk sagt, aha, ja men då köper jag vaslet.
Alltså vi försöker vara väldigt noga med att inte trycka på massa effekter.
Men är det det som får er att stoppa eller är det någon sorts er, för ni kan ju egentligen ta fram en, jag kan inte så mycket om just tester boosters, men kan ni inte ta fram en testbooster, lägga i ett preparat som inte är olagligt än, sälja det ett år och sen, ja.
Det hade vi väl kunnat göra.
Jag bara hittar på.
Ja, jag fattar.
Men är det det som stoppar er eller är det att du känner att nej, vi kanske inte ska in i detta?
Jag tror också att kommersiellt är inte kanon.
Jag tror till exempel att en av anledningen till att vi har kunnat ha, exempelvis vitamin well samarbetet, är ju att vi har varit ganska legitima.
Alltså, vi har inte jobbat så mycket i gråa zon, så att säga.
Så jag tror ändå att, jag vill inbilla mig att, plus att segmentet finns redan på något sätt.
Om man vill köpa test och booster så finns det.
Man kan inte heller tillföra någon smak där, eller någon konsistens, eller någonting annat som uppar det.
Jag menar inte att det beropades en moralens väktare här, men generellt har vi en skepsis och samman med fettförbrännare, det blir saker som drar mot knark till olika utsträckning.
Det är väl också en grej att...
Det är något att tänka på.
Jag tror också att det är det här.
Vi har väldigt mycket...
Vi är ganska många idrottare har vi haft i det här tidigt.
Av några anledningar.
Alltså folk som inte minst har naturligt lyftar och sånt, men också andra idrottare.
Det är liksom allt från ping-spelare till annat.
Det är ju folk som testas väldigt mycket.
Det är ju också för att ni har kört den cleana looken liksom.
Ja men jag tror det.
För att ni inte har satt Ronny Coleman på framsidan.
Lite så och då är det också det att när man börjar hålla på med väldigt mycket grejer som spelar i gråzonen, då är det ju ändå mycket större risk för misstag.
Alltså jag tror att väldigt få svenska märken vill blanda i dopning gärna i sina produkter.
Men det är ju ändå vissa där folk har testat positivt ett gäng gånger från samma märken så att säga.
Och då kan väl jag tänka att om du slänger i väldigt många experimentella ingredienser, då ökar risken att nåt ger utslag på nåt på nåt sätt då.
Så det är väl lite det.
Och det hade ju varit den ultimata katastrofen för oss, som det var liksom, trullsmörgård från tas OS-guldet i pingis hade druckit vassleprotein.
Så kan vi ju inte ha det, helt enkelt.
Nej, det låter väl sunt.
Jag har några småfrågor.
Jag ska försöka att inte sväva ut i dem.
Det är väl jag som svävar ut.
Ja, jag har inte känt för att prata.
Nummer ett, så undrar jag, hur länge du orkar sitta och prata podd.
Du har ju gjort det några gånger liksom.
Alltså, det här är jag och Alex pratat om.
Vi tror ju liksom att själva poddandet, där känner vi liksom, man skulle ju aldrig säga någonting om hur man känner i framtiden, men för oss är inte den, förutom att boka gäster och få ihop schemat och sådär, så är det liksom ingen belastning.
Alltså, är det någonting jag skulle pensionera mig ifrån, så är det snarare allt det andra jobbet.
Att sitta och prata podd, det är liksom, som nu när du och jag pratar, då har ju Lina fyra barn på övervåningen, så att semestern pågår här nere i källaren där jag sitter.
Jag har samma sak, jag har stängt av telefonen och alla kollegor tar alla mail istället.
Ja du ser det är fantastiskt.
Det är rätt nice.
Så jag vill säga, podden känner väl egentligen ingen sådär tydligt utgångsdaten för det.
Men är du pratsam i vanliga livet liksom?
Kan du bara köra på?
Ja men det kan jag nog.
Alltså vi har ju aldrig, en fördel är att vi har ju aldrig jobbat med något manus till någon podd, det kommer ju då inte, kanske som en skräll för någon som har lyssnat heller, men det går nog egentligen att trycka på play-knappen så kan jag prata om nästan de flesta ämnen också.
Jag sa ju det till dig här innan vi tryckte på play här med att jag försökte göra lite research på det, jag har ju lyssnat på otaliga timmar av era poddar här, och det är helt hopplöst för det liksom.
Man har ätit timmar om bara, den här lampskärmen är snygg typ, man bara va fan till, såhär öppnar jag en Nocco, haha.
Ja, idea.
Jag är fascinerad, jag pratar ju helst inte med någon och skriver helst bara sms och gärna bara och.
Och min flickvän, vi flyttade för två år sedan till ett nytt hus och då sa hon till mig att nu går du fan ut och du hälsar på grannarna vid lekplatsen för här ska vi bo.
Så du säger hej, du säger vem du är och vilka dina barn är.
Ja men grejen är att det sjuka är att jag kommer fram till målet att jag inte är så jävla extrovert.
Jag pratar väldigt mycket men jag är inte sådär du vet.
Jag älskar att träffa nya människor eller jag vill liksom, nej jag är ju ganska mycket av en house cat alltså.
Jag håller med liksom.
Men däremot så när jag väl gör det så pratar jag väl mycket.
Jag är liksom inte så nervös kanske för de sociala interaktionerna på det viset.
Men jag är ju helst, det bor ju en eremit här.
Alltså som längtar till att sätta sig under en gran bara.
Liksom, så är det ju.
Ja det är bara så skönt att inte lyssna på folk.
Men skitsamma vi ska inte fastna.
Men om vi säger det, det är min andra.
Jag har två frågor till som är små här.
Den ena är, du har ju det som väldigt många skulle beskriva som ett drömyrke.
Få peta lite i allting, du får jobba med det du tycker är kul och det går uppenbart bra för er.
Är det det här som du tycker är drömjobbet eller vad har du för, eller drömlivet kanske man ska säga.
Vad hade du förändrat?
Det hade väl varit att ta bort jobbet.
Om man nu blir tvungen att jobba över huvud taget, då är det här bra.
Det är ingen snack på det.
Du tycker inte att jobbet är en tillgång?
Jag är ju så lat.
Vad ska du annars göra?
Ligga hemma?
Det finns ju inte.
Fyra barn fyller jag ändå tagan.
Då är det inte skönt att komma iväg.
Jag jobbar ju hemma, vi har ju ingen kontor heller.
Vi sitter ju bara hemma.
För Alex bor i Västerås.
Det är ingen bra lösning för er känns det.
Nej, men det är nästan så här.
Det är nästan sättet vi kan få ihop det här.
Jag och min fru som jobbar på tyngden, vi liksom stafett jobbar ju lite.
Vi har ju två barn i väg på förskolan, men vi är två bebisar hemma.
Vilket innebär att om man inte lyckas få dem att ta en siesta samtidigt, då får ju liksom en jobba mindre intensivt.
Eller vad ska jag säga.
Man får jobba, det är ju ett väldigt speciellt schema.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, om vi omsätter 160 miljoner är fem pers, bara av två pers är att gifta och ha fyra barn ihop och växeljobba hemma.
Men det är inte det bästa.
Nej, det är så det ser ut.
Det hoppas jag inte.
Man gör vad man kan med det man har.
Nej men, jobbet är väldigt roligt som jobb betraktat.
Men sen är det ju så att det är klart att eftersom jag på något sätt är ytterst ansvarig så finns det ju ändå, ja det vet ju du, man har någon slags ansvar för hur det går.
Det hade varit jävligt skönt att inte ha något av det.
Alltså att det går ju inte bara, jag har ju aldrig liksom semester eller någonting, jag har ju aldrig haft det ledigt.
Så att det är ju, och då är det ju inte primärt, alltså det är ju inte primärt det här som man tänker, oj nu är det inte semester, nu går jag till jobbet så sitter jag då åtta timmar, men så att säga ansvaret pågår ju alltid.
Om någonting händer eller vad det nu spelar ingen roll om det är julafton, eller alltså då är det ju bara att göra.
Så är det ju, det stängs ju aldrig av.
Så för mig är det nog snarare än andra drömyrken, så är det väl mycket tid på softlocket i så fall som hade lakat.
Fattar, eller stäng av ansvaret.
Ja precis, bara sitta och prata i en podcast istället.
Perfekt.
Och sen tänkte jag slutligen, om någon person vill in i träningsvärlden och jobba, alltså det finns ju en miljon PTS som har försökt starta egna kostigskott, och det finns ju en miljon människor som har startat och försökt få igång, ska man säga, hemsidor eller poddar eller allt möjligt.
Har du något tips för att de faktiskt ska kunna leva på det?
Ja det är ju alltså, det är ju inte lätt, alltså för att de, tyvärr.
Jag har alltid detta, detta är den enda återkommande frågan och den är alltid lika deppig.
Ja men för jag, men det här gäller ju inte ens bara träningsbranschen, fast det är mer här, men man ska ju komma ihåg att alla så här, de flesta nystartade verksamheter går i omkull, det är rena.
Sen i träningsbranschen är det ju lite speciellt, för ta som personligt tränare om vi bara tar det yrket till exempel, så är det ju alltid utmålat som, så länge jag varit verksam i tränningsbranschen, det är sedan 2003 då, så har det alltid varit att det här är ett framtidsyrke.
Träning är också, det här är framtidens jobb och så vidare, men det är också så att det finns jävligt många som går på ett gym som tänker att det här vore ju soft att göra.
I Grinberg finns det ett väldigt stort utbud av PTS.
Alla större kedjor har ju alltid den här filosofin att du får betalt efter hur mycket kunder du har och i princip blir du fulltäcknad så har du en vanlig lön.
Men du måste vara där hela tiden för att få ihop en halvtid nästan.
Det är en stökig bransch att hålla på i, om du inte har någon namn, någon anledning.
Det här ändras lite, är du en stor profil på sociala medier.
Då kan du sälja sådana här färdiga upplägg.
Folk sitter ju nu bara med all coaching, går ju via appar.
Du får skräddas i det där recept, men det är ju liksom gjort redan i appen.
Så du bara kan klicka iväg det.
Då kanske du kan få ekonomi i det.
Men sen, jag tror att den stora grejen man ska fråga sig när man funderar på det här med att etablera någon typ av egen verksamhet är om det liksom, är det det man vill?
Jag tycker att det finns en kultur nu som är väldigt sådär entreprenöriell.
Det är nästan lite fult att vara anställd, jag ska inte säga det men inte fult.
Jag fattar vad du menar, det har ju verkligen bytt de senaste åren att alla vill ha eget företag även om de bara är egna och gör samma sak.
Exakt, tidigare skulle man säga, då Joel jobbade du inte på Volvo, har du inte gjort en karriär?
Du skulle säga att det är så bra nu, för nu är jag faktiskt ganska högt uppsatt chef där.
Men idag är det ingenting, det är mycket bättre att du har ett eget företag, det är ju coolare.
Men, det finns ju fortfarande någonting.
Dels när man börjar då, då är man ju ofta ganska ensam.
Alltså det är ingen annan som bryr sig om det här skiten än du.
Och ingen är riktigt glad om det går bra förutom du.
Och går det dåligt så är det bara du som sitter med ångesten.
Och du har liksom inte det här härliga att gå till en arbetsplats där det liksom finns fruktfat och du har möten med trevliga kolleg.
Alltså det där är ju borta då.
Så varken Tyngr eller gymkompaniets kan man gå till?
Nej exakt.
Då får man inga fruktfat.
Nej men sen ser det i det här att om det går dåligt och du är den som har företag så är det ju liksom det är du som kommer i sista rummet så att säga.
Du får ju betala dina anställda först och om det finns något över då får du betala dig själv.
Sen får man ju, om du nu har anställda, då blir det ju ännu mer ansvar för då har du sagt jag är övertygad i Roffe om att han skulle börja jobba här och nu ser det fan kinkigt ut.
Och då har man ju jävla dåligt samvete om man liksom blir tvungen att säga till Roffe då att jag vet att du gav upp det där Volvo-giget men nu har vi inget jobb här.
Så att det är inte själv, liksom så här trivs man med den här tillvaron?
För mig, jag kommer ju från, mina föräldrar har ju alltid haft eget företag då.
Så att för mig är det så, det själva sättet att leva är så normalt och en vanlig anställning hade direkt för mig känts som ett fängelse.
Att jag skulle behöva fråga någon, om jag skulle säga så här fan vi tänker åka upp till till liksom Linas föräldrar i Torsby, är det okej?
Förstår du det?
Det är för mig otänkbart.
Jag bara åker ju.
Jag frågar ju inte då.
Och den grejen är ju så...
Den är så mycket värd för mig.
På samma sätt om det är liksom så här fan, nu måste min dotter Beatrice gå till tandläkaren.
Då kan jag ju bara ta henne till tandläkaren.
Jag behöver inte säga till någon, jag kommer att vara borta på onsdag mellan 11 och 1.
När jag säger att jag är aldrig ledig, så kan jag i princip alltid bestämma mig för att vara ledig också.
Det där är för mig jättemycket värd.
Det finns väl något...
Jag vet inte.
Så här har jag varit uppvuxen, det är allt jag vet.
Men det är den stora grejen för dig med att vara egen?
Det är det verkligen.
Det är inte så att jag tänkte från början att...
Du tänkte inte att du skulle tjäna pengar eller bygga ett legacy?
Att det skulle vara så självklart att det var mer lukrativt att vara egen, än att en tydligare väg hade varit att satsa på att bli banker i London.
Om man nu var ut efter pengarna direkt.
Sen är det såklart att det går väldigt bra om man är egen.
Så kommer det generellt att vara mer pengar än om du är anställd.
Om bolaget går bra, så är det ju.
Men det är ju ändå, jag skulle säga att gör man det som en rent ekonomisk kalkyl, då är det ändå lite knivigt.
Det är inte självklart att du sitter med den vinnande lotten.
Nej, det är ju nästan tvärtom.
Som du sa, det är ju ganska många som bara går under.
Ja men verkligen, och vi hade det ju lite riggat också.
Vi nådde ju ut redan innan vi började.
Så vi startade ju inte med två tomma händer på det viset.
Så det var ju liksom en jävla fördel mot att börja på noll då.
Sen är det ju så här, jag menar det är ju ingen som säger när när saker går åt helvete.
Om man kollar, det verkar ju som varenda företag som folk startar i en framgångssaga.
Och sen tänkte man fan, drev inte han det här enormt framgångsrika, varför gör han inte det längre?
Det är ju sällan det liksom sägs något om det.
Så att intrycket är ju starta eget, bli svinrik, kör Lamborghini.
På något sätt då.
Det är ju inte riktigt sanningen då.
Så mitt främsta råd är väl bara att fundera över.
Sammanfattar är positivt.
Fundera över om du verkligen vill driva eget.
Tycker du att den här grejen att liksom med självbestämmandet och allt det är en stor vinst i sig?
Och är du inte heller, man ska nog inte ha för mycket demoner och vara för ångestladdad, för då blir det för jobbigt med alla siffror och dagar du säljer sämre och kostnader.
Man måste nog kunna ha den här förmågan att stänga av lite för att må bättre.
För då menar jag att du inte ligger hela natten och tänker, va fan, hur ska det här gå?
För då är det ju ingen rolig tillvaro.
För det är ju också någonstans så att, jag hävdar alltid att, varför vill man tjäna pengar?
Varför vill man ha mycket pengar?
Det är ju för att man tänker att de här pengarna kommer på något sätt göra mig lyckligare.
Om det är att jag kan bo i det här huset eller jag kan köra den här bilen, jag blir gladare av det.
Men om liksom vägen till att få de här pengarna är kantad av dåligt mående, då blir ju ekvationen, då haltar den ju så att säga.
För då mår du dåligt för att må bra, så att säga.
Det är ändå inte...
Alltså idag är också viktigt, inte bara om tio år.
Om man inte nyuter av processen så är det ju ingen större...
Nej.
Jag tror inte det.
Jag tycker ofta när man läser, eller jag lyssnar fruktansvärt mycket podd och då är det ju mycket så här intervjuerpoddar och då intervjuar de väldigt ofta av någon anledning folk som har ett företag i ett år typ.
Så att då säger de alltid ja det har varit så tungt, jag har grät varje dag och det var jättejobbigt.
Och man bara men varför?
Du har inte ens börjat inom problemen.
Men kom ju typ när när kolleger kommer eller när du har ett rullande maskineri för då har du saker att betala.
Ja.
På riktigt.
Jaja.
Att det blir värre.
Ja men och sen så är det det här jag, alltså en grej jag har underskattat det var ju liksom, jag tänkte alltid att den stora grejen med det här är ju kan man få någon att vilja köpa ens produkter.
Det är det svåra.
Att få dig att säga fan, jag har 200 spänn som ligger här.
Nu tänker jag skicka dem till dig för en produkt.
Det trodde jag var det svåra men det som typ är mest krångel det är ju för mig då att säga fan Joel, kan du skicka dem här, alltså att själv kunna köpa in det på ett sätt.
Det är det, det är nästan ännu värre.
Så att, nej det är, nej jag vet fan, det är nog lätt att liksom gå bort sig lite tror jag.
Och återigen, fundera, överhuvudtaget när man tänker hur man ska leva sitt liv, då är jag alltid väldigt kär i att man verkligen ska tänka så att man gör de grejer som man själv mår bra av och inte det som, alltså, vill du verkligen renovera köket?
Är det verkligen något du vill eller har du bara sett att alla gör det?
På något sätt.
Alltså, så att man liksom tänker igenom allt lite, för då tror jag det blir bättre i allmänhet.
Jag tycker att det var ett bra sista råd, så jag tror vi pausar av där.
Andreas, du är ett fucking proffs på det här ju.
Jag tycker det har varit ett jätteintressant samtal och jag tror att det är många som får med sig många tankar.
Ja men vad roligt.
Riktigt kul att få vara med.
Jag vägde mig här i Föregård och fick en chock.
Och så bara, fan helvete vad det har gått ut för.
Så jag känner just nu att jag får vara med på det här tåget.